six months since the start of the
Ukraine war and the parallels with
Taiwan remain in Focus large
authoritarian Powers with global
Ambitions claiming Sovereign rights over
a smaller Democratic neighbor the
Kremlin has steadfastly dismissed
Ukraine's right to exist as a nation
insisting that it historically belongs
to Russia likewise China sees the island
of Taiwan as an indivisible part of the
Homeland and has promised a military
response should it ever declare
independence
Taiwan fears that it could be next to
suffer an invasion are clearly not
unjustified but six months after Russia
crossed the border into Ukraine East
China any closer to doing the same in
Taiwan recent months have seen
attentions across the Taiwan Strait
climbed to the highest level in years
spurred on by high-ranking visits from
the United States House speaker Nancy
Pelosi's trip to Taipei just a few weeks
ago Drew an angry response from Beijing
which launched massive military drills
around Taiwan
the parallels haven't been lost on
Russia's president who'd loudly supports
China's territorial claim to Taiwan and
accuses the U.S of provocation
Americans the American Adventure in
relation to Taiwan is not just a trick
by an individual irresponsible
politician but part of a purposeful
conscious U.S strategy to destabilize
and make chaotic the situation in the
region and the world
for more on this let's bring in DW's
William young in our Taipei Bureau
William what is the feeling over there
has the Ukraine war signaled a new phase
in China's aggression towards Taiwan
I think there's definitely an added
feeling of urgency over here in Taipei
since February especially among the
citizens we have already seen an
increase of people participating in
self-organized uh training for self-help
and first aid uh kind of activities and
at the same time there are also
companies private companies that are
offering weapons boot camps for those
who are hoping to acquire more combat
Readiness experience and at the same
time people are also expressing their
willingness to be participating in the
government's renewed kind of increased
intensity for the reservist training
schemes so I think these are all the
signs that compared to the past when
Tony's people felt like the military
threat from China is still kind of like
a distant thing in the future the
Ukraine war made them realize that
rather than hoping that other countries
will stepping and intervene when China
prepares to militarily invade Taiwan
they Taiwanese people should also have
the ability to defend itself because at
the end of the day they think and they
see what happened to Ukraine is that
most of the actual fighting is coming
from the Taiwanese people and the
Taiwanese troops you know you talked
about international support let's talk
about that Ukraine has had a string of
high-level visits from U.S officials as
the Ukraine war strengthened
International support for Taiwan
yes definitely I think we saw a couple
different delegations visiting Taiwan
including the high very controversial
visit of the U.S House speaker Pelosi
and even though that visit really
triggered a heightened response from
China including a seven-day military
exercise around Taiwan but we are
continuing to see different delegations
including from the US and currently
there is a Japanese parliamentary
delegation and later this year there is
going to be a UK Parliament delegation a
Canadian Parliament delegation and the
Danish Parliament delegation all
scheduled to visit Taiwan in the coming
months I think these are all signs that
despite beijing's warning and these very
provocative and heightened and more
dangerous kind of military exercise and
activities around Taiwan it is not
deterring the International Community to
show its support by sending their
delegations to visit Taiwan thank you so
much for joining us William young DW
reporter in Taipei
so while China has set its sights on
Taiwan it has firmly refused to condemn
Russia for its war in Ukraine something
born out of the No Limits friendship
Chinese president Xi Jinping and Russian
President Vladimir Putin agreed to at
the Winter Olympics in Beijing in early
February and since then China has sought
to frame Russia's actions in Ukraine as
being the only option Moscow had to push
back against U.S led expansionism
the key to solving the Ukraine crisis
lies in the hands of the United States
and NATO we hope the United States and
NATO as the culprits of the crisis can
reflect on their roles in the Ukraine
crisis take up their due
responsibilities and make practical
actions to resolve the conflict
and for more on the Chinese thinking
here let's bring in Reed Standish he's a
correspondent with radio free Europe
covering China's influence across
Eastern Europe and Central Asia and he
joins me now from Prague Reed welcome
does China see an opportunity with the
Ukraine war to dislodge the United
States from its position of influence in
Asia
um well I there's no doubt that the
Ukraine war has changed things I think
geopolitically everywhere but I think
especially in Asia and especially in
regards to to Taiwan obviously Taiwan
has presented itself as a bit of a foil
um for everything that's been happening
in Ukraine over the last six months so I
think for Taiwan if anything I don't
know if it's seeing it as an opportunity
to necessarily dislodge the United
States from Asia but I think it's quite
worried that this is perhaps one of the
last Windows of opportunity to limit
American influence and especially
American attempts to reorient its
military presence and a lot of its
foreign policy making towards the
Pacific away from Europe This invasion
in effect has forced the United States
to turn its attention towards Europe at
a time when American leaders have been
talking about uh China and the Pacific
being the main theater of The Next
Century so I think China sees the
Ukraine war as this this factor that has
really changed things and I think that
they know know that they have a short
window and if they're going to secure
their interests and prevent America from
from going against theirs
right let's speak about the Chinese
influence in the Pacific and uh in the
in in wider Asia does the No Limits
partnership it has with Russia give it
an upper hand in achieving that goal
well it's
it's declared this no limits partnership
in Beijing
um at the launch of the Winter Olympics
um it's clear that policy Bankers in
Beijing they they are invested in this
relationship and given everything that
we've seen Russia do whether that's been
you know war crimes everything all the
the violence and violations we've seen
on the ground in Ukraine none of that
has really seemed to have damaged this
partnership and the main reason for that
is that Beijing knows that it needs
um a superpower like Russia one with
especially its Security Council seat and
its nuclear power or its nuclear weapons
and its influence around the world on
its side if it's going to uh grow its
influence and especially if it's going
to resist what it sees as U.S enrochment
on its interests right you spoke about
Taiwan as well let's just talk a bit
about that now there's a lot of views
that when it comes to the lessons that
China is drawing from the Ukraine war
but very specifically Reid is it is is
China watching the Western response to
Russia as an indicator of what could be
in store for it if it invaded Taiwan
indicator of how the West had react
Taipei has also been watching very
closely
um uh learning military lessons from
Ukraine on the ground about how to
resist the potential Invasion but going
back to your original question
um I I think definitely there's been a
lot of uh especially in regards to
sanctions I think that the the economic
response especially from the European
Union and the United States and the West
at large and how unified it has been and
how deep cutting it has been I think not
only caught Moscow off guard but also
cut Beijing off guard and obviously the
Chinese economy is much larger than the
Russian economy it's much more
integrated globally and the West is much
more dependent on it than say Russia is
um so I think that maybe Beijing feels
it has a little bit more cover here in
terms of getting hit by sanctions but
seeing that kind of response I think has
as we're in China have they been looking
into and exploring different ways about
how to protect themselves especially
against uh sanctions which could
obviously hurt their economy which is uh
the sen natural factor of the Communist
party's hold on on power in China
Reid we lived there for the time being
but thank you so much for joining us
today read Standish from Radio free
Europe thank you so much
like China India too refused to condemn
Russia for its Invasion but unlike China
it wasn't an act of support for Moscow
but a strategic choice for New Delhi the
two countries have very strong ties
dating back to the Cold War and Russia
still supplies the bulk of India's
weapons it's a time-tested friendship
that saw the foreign Ministers of both
sides meet in Delhi in early April with
Russia only too Keen to offer India
whatever it needed
uh we will be ready to supply to India
any uh Goods which India wants to buy
and I have no doubt that a way would be
out to uh
bypass the artificial impediments which
illegal Universal sanctions by the West
created
and we saw how despite sanctions India
increased its purchases of discounted
Russian oil by a factor of five when
compared to last year so does that
provide an indication of where Indian
foreign policy is now headed DW's Delhi
bureau chief Amrita Chima has more
India appears to have found its balance
on the Diplomatic tightrope when it
comes to the war in Ukraine it's no
longer feeling diffident or defensive
about refusing to condemn Russia's
invasion of Ukraine there's now talk
about balancing India's interests and
India's right to buy cheap Russian oil
if it wants now recently the Ukrainian
foreign minister said that India must be
mindful that every barrel of oil that
comes from Russia contains Ukrainian
blood now his counterpart the Indian
foreign minister SJ Shankar said he has
a moral duty to look after the needs of
his people
so in this diplomatic churn you see
India's feeling more confident it wants
to enhance its diplomatic space on the
international stage it wants to use
leverage for its own strategic interests
especially when it comes to countries
like China
the two neighbors are Rivals and have a
very tense relationship now in this
situation if Russia and China come
closer together things could get very
difficult for India because after all
India is very reliant on Russia in many
ways specially military hardware
so India might aspire to have a neutral
position in a multi-polar world but if
things go the way they might go with
Russia and China coming closer together
it would not be easy for India at all